aujourd'hui nous partons à la rencontre
de Sandra qui a bénéficié du dispositif
appelé ADN l'aide départementale à la
création d'une entreprise à nouvelle une
mesure mise en place par le département
qui permet aux personnes dans une
situation précaire ayant un projet de
création d'entreprise économiquement
viable de bénéficier d'un apport
personnel sous forme d'un prêt sans
intérêt
l'ADN est une aide du département
permettant de bénéficier d'un apport
personnel sous forme de prix de maximum
8000 euros sans intérêt avec différé de
remboursement mais c'est aussi un
accompagnement technique durant les deux
années suivant la création de
l'entreprise
bonjour Sandra bonjour Alexandra alors
dites nous à quoi vous a servi l'ADN
concrètement lors de la création de
votre entreprise alors il y a deux ans
de cela j'ai voulu créer ma boutique en
ligne de prêt-à-porter féminin donc ça
m'a permis de créer mon site internet de
me déplacer en métropole pour les
premiers stocks et également de créer ce
showroom qui a été réalisé par mon mari
bien sûr et pour pouvoir le privatiser
car ça c'est unique ici et en quoi c'est
important d'avoir un apport financier
lorsque l'on se lance dans son activité
au chômage il y a deux ans de cela et
n'ayant pas de fonds propres donc ça m'a
permis justement de de réaliser tout ce
que je voulais grâce à l'ADN et
racontez-nous comment se sont passés vos
démarches tout au long de votre demande
alors ça a commencé en septembre 2020
j'ai pu mettre en place tous les
documents nécessaires que j'ai fournis
justement la BGE qui nous a soutenu
depuis le départ ça a été bouclé au bout
de deux mois en novembre 2020 merci
Sandra merci Alexandre
[Musique]
l'ADN est une avance d'un montant
maximal de 8000 euros pouvant être
accordés soit en totalité sous forme de
prix lors de la création dans
l'entreprise soit en partie en prêt et
le reliquat en subvention la subvention
devra être demandée dans les 24 mois
suivant l'immatriculation de l'activité
le prêt est remboursable sans intérêt en
42 mensualités maximum avec la
possibilité de différer le démarrage des
remboursements
bonjour Christine bonjour Alexandre
alors dites-nous concrètement comment se
présente l'ADEME l'ADN est une aide au
développement des entreprises nouvelles
qui est un prêt à taux zéro qui va de 0
à 8000 euros et qui peut être demandé en
amont c'est au moment de la création
d'entreprise mais également si on n'a
pas sollicité la totalité du montant au
bout du 25ème mois sous forme de
subventions sur le reliquat jusqu'à 8000
euros et qui peut bénéficier de cette
aide les bénéficiaires d'Aden sont les
demandeurs d'emploi depuis 6 mois des
bénéficiaires des minima sociaux RSA ASS
etc et il faut que des revenus soit
inférieurs à 10000 euros par an alors
expliquez-nous comment faire une demande
pour un bénéficier de l'ADN alors
quelqu'un qui voudrait bénéficier d'Aden
va passer par le un membre du réseau
Point chance qui est un réseau
d'accompagnement à la création
d'entreprise qui va analyser avec le
demandeur avec le porteur de projet la
viabilité de son projet puis présenter
le dossier au département pour décision
et quelle est l'intérêt de l'ADEME alors
Adam s'adresse à un public en difficulté
demandeur d'emploi depuis plus de 6 mois
bénéficiaire des minima sociaux autant
de personnes qui ont peu ou pas accès
aux réseaux bancaires traditionnel et
effectivement ce financement là avec une
possibilité différée sur 40 de mois en
remboursement permet d'avoir un apport
personnel ou en tout cas de démarrer
l'entreprise très bien merci Christine
merci Alexandre
grâce à cette aide du département de
nombreuses structures et entreprises ont
pu voir le jour l'ADN permet aux
entrepreneurs d'être plus sereins
financièrement lors du lancement de leur
projet et cela leur permet également
d'avoir un accompagnement technique sur
deux ans en cas de besoin
[Musique]
si vous souhaitez avoir plus
d'informations sur l'ADN n'hésitez pas
vous avez toutes les coordonnées qui
s'affichent sur votre écran le
département des générations c'est fini
si vous souhaitez revoir cet épisode
ainsi que les précédents rendez-vous sur
nos sites et nos réseaux sociaux quant à
moi je vous retrouve très vite pour un
nouvel épisode à bientôt
depuis juin 2010 les assistants
maternels peuvent travailler en dehors
domicile et se regrouper pour accueillir
des enfants au sein d'une maison
d'assistante maternelle une MAM la
semaine prochaine je vous amène à
théâtre on nous rencontrerons Julie qui
grâce au Département a pu monter une MAM
avec d'autres assistants maternels
[Musique]